Good morning, everybody, and thank you all for joining us on
this session on structural insights to cancer biology and
therapy. I am Babis Kalodimos. I will be chairing this session.
And I was told, and that's my understanding,
that
major symposia at AACR that are
focused on structural biology are rather uncommon.
I was told that this is probably the first one that is really focused on structural
biology, so I guess it's no accident that we are somewhere here isolated
in Room 28, very far away from other people.
But of course, this is not because structure is peripheral to cancer
biology, right? We've seen, of course, already some very beautiful
structures presented here, but it's just rather, as I said, that the
impact has been often embedded across disciplines.
So this is then a different kind of session.
It's an opportunity, I think, to bring this impact of structural biology into
focus. And what you will be hearing in the next
three talks, I think, is also evidence about how the
field has evolved over the recent years.
Now, structural biology is no longer, of course,
about determining single static structures.
It is now providing very direct mechanistic
insight into how cancer-relevant proteins are
regulated, the different mechanisms, how they are inhibited, how they get
activated, how they get
often dysregulated, and that, of course, will
result in disease. But also how signaling complexes
assemble and how these processes can be
pharmacologically exploited and manipulated.
So in this session then, we will explore.
There are three different talks, and then they will highlight, I
think, the strengths of structural biology, always complemented, of course, by
other techniques as well. The first talk will be
on how advances in cryo-EM computation and chemical
biology are enabling the identification and targeting of
dynamic
or inducible protein states for that matter, that also include through
molecular glue strategies. And that will be delivered by Eric Fischer
from Dana-Farber.
The second one will be about the architecture of membrane proximal
signaling assemblies, integrating inputs from receptor tyrosine
kinases and RAS to control pathways such as, for example,
PI3K. And that will be delivered by Natalia Djura from UCSF.
And the final talk will be delivered by me on mechanisms
of protein kinase regulation, where now activity emerges from
underlying conformational landscapes, and where these dynamic states,
of course, create new opportunities to achieve selectivity by
targeting very specific and often very low populated, very
transient functional conformations.
So without any further ado, I would like to ask Eric to
please deliver the first talk of this session. Thank you.
Thank you for this introduction, and it's a great pleasure to be
here and to see a sizable number of people in this room, despite being at
the furthest corner of the building.
There's a couple of disclosures I have to make.
The one that's probably the most relevant is Neomorph, which is a company focused
on molecular glue degraders.
And what I thought I'd do today for this talk is I'm going to give you a bit of an
update on what's really been a decade-long quest to
accelerate and systematize the discovery of molecular glue
degraders, and then follow up with two small vignettes
on how we use this to, one, really rapidly
develop selective chemical probes, and also how we're expanding the
concept to go beyond the canonical or most
well-understood recruitment of cereblon neosubstrates.
So
let me get started by just very briefly introducing the ubiquitin
proteasome system, and I'm really only going to focus on one aspect of that, where
ubiquitin ligases are the principal machines in cells that attack
proteins for degradation. And so you get these polyubiquitin chains that
then lead to degradation by the proteasome.
And this is really all you need to know for today.
There's a lot more complexity to ubiquitin, but the fundamental
aspect is that you have these ubiquitin ligases that ubiquitylate and degrade
targets. And target protein degradation, as we know it
today, really goes back about 20, 25 years, where it was
first conceptualized by Craig Crews and Ray Deshaies, and I don't have time to talk
about this. But what really put it on the map was a series of discoveries
about 10, 15 years ago, where initially
Arshi Handa from Japan figured out that thalidomide
binds cereblon. And then a series of discoveries
from Ben Ebert, Bill Kelden, Nico Tome, and others,
groups at Celgene, put a puzzle together where thalidomide actually
works as a small molecule degrader, binding a ubiquitin ligase,
repurposing this ubiquitin ligase to now degrade the transcription
factors, ECRs and IOLAS.
And that was so significant because from one day to the other,
we had clinical proof of concept for a novel modality that
allowed to, in principle, target essentially any protein in
the human proteome. And particularly the first
targets that were identified, ECRs and IOLAS, represent one of the most
intractable, or to that point, intractable families of proteins, transcription
factors that often look like these piles of spaghetti on the top right.
So that got everyone excited, including me and
many others, and we started really thinking, how do we expand this
principle? Can we make these molecules to do other things?
Can we make them to target novel targets within this
transcription factor space?
AndStructural biology was really essential here because
the first couple of insights that really led to the expansion of the space came
from our structural understanding
of these recruitment events.
And these are just two examples
of ternary complex structures. On the left side, casein kinase 1 alpha,
determined by Georg Petzold in Nico Thommes lab.
And then GSPD1 on the right, a structure determined by Phil
Gambelin's group at Celgene back then, that for the
first time revealed what's now known as a G-loop background.
This motif shown in the middle, which is this small loop
that despite complete absence of sequence conservation between the different
targets, mediated recruitment in a structurally defined way.
And for anyone who has a bit of a sense of protein structure,
this is a very common motif you'll find in thousands of proteins.
And so we immediately thought there must be a whole sea of targets out there that
are potentially tractable for this modality.
And this really initiated our then long quest,
more than a decade now, to find these targets.
And what I'll give you now is just a bit of an update on some of
the recent advances we've made, and I'm
only highlighting a couple of people here, but it's really work by all of the lab
over the last 10 years that moved us forward.
And the reason we are so interested in expanding this modality is because if
you go back in therapeutic sciences history, every time
we've enabled a new modality, we've really made tremendous progress in
targeting novel biology, novel pharmacology.
The best-known example, probably therapeutic antibodies that came about
maybe now 40 years ago and brought the entire cell surface
into scope. And I think target protein degradation does have the
possibility to similarly expand the pharmacology accessible, and we
are now also thinking about using similar proximity
modalities for other biology.
We've took really a dual track approach to this.
There was one, trying to scale mass spectrometry as a discovery
method that allows us, in an unbiased way, to look at targets of small molecules,
combine this with expanding libraries.
And then second, really use structural biology to drive predictive algorithms
that allow us to predict those ternary complex structures, which reinforms the
chemistry to really expand the chemical space we
sample. And
early work really allowed us to expand this to other zinc finger
transcription factors, which was an obvious place to be.
But we very quickly, in collaboration with Nathaniel Gray's lab,
figured out that there are kinases and many other things you could target with
these molecules in a very highly selective way.
To me, this is still kind of remarkable how, despite this very common
structural motif, you can get selectivity across the
entire proteome.
We also quickly realized that selectivity is really
imposed by very
limited chemical features that add a bond here or subtract
a bond here or create a little bit of a clash there.
And that really poses a challenge for most computational chemistry
approaches, which are not really
built to deal with these composite protein-protein small molecule
interfaces. And
one thing we've been trying to do over the last two, three years is
to
get to predictive models that are better at this quest.
And we quickly realized the one big missing piece is
data. And so
to get to predictive models, we need to extend data sets.
And we've been really trying to do this by scaling across a couple of
domains,
understanding molecular recognition, so scaling structural biology to get
structures of very diverse proteins, and also use predicted
models that we now have high confidence in to extend those data
sets.
Really scale the libraries to get chemical features.
And then one of the major pushes has been to drop the cost per data
point on the unbiased mass spectrometry-based discovery.
And I'll just give you a brief update on that.
So initially we've used what's really been the enabling
technology, global proteomics, to just look for dropouts of
target, because the beauty of these molecules is that they induce degradation of a
target. So you can just measure comparative protein abundance between a
treated and untreated cell, and you easily identify targets.
We scaled that reasonably, mostly through the
emergence of data-independent acquisition methods and faster
mass spectrometers, but it doesn't quite scale to the level we need.
So one of the things we've recently been doing is
adding another workflow to this pipeline, where we essentially
adapted an old method, affinity purification mass spectrometry,
using
modern instrumentation and automation, which not only increases
sensitivity because it detects the recruitment event itself,
but also scales to the point where we now can generate thousands and thousands of
data points.
And this is just, I think, an interesting reflection on the development here,
where when we started in 2012,
it cost us upwards of $20,000 to profile
an individual molecule. We're now on
less than $500 per molecule, and
probably less than that. So this, for the first time, really
puts us in a position where we can generate the data that's
necessary
to train potential predictive models.
We've built the back end of this through computational methods.
So we have predictive algorithms now that sort through hits.
And the important piece is that a lot of those predictions are actually pretty
accurate. So this is just contrasting in the ribbon diagrams,
structure predictions. And then in the surface representations, you have
the corresponding cryo-EM maps, and they nearly perfectly
overlap. So we're getting really high confidence in those predictions.
AndWhat these
little optimizations on all the pieces have done for us is that they've
really cut down the timeline to discovery so we can tap into these large
proteomics databases. We have set up in high throughput
screens that we use to follow up and identify molecules.
And then we very rapidly go to cryo-EM.
We can screen in-house on a Tundra microscope,
quickly get conditions that work, and then just scale up and collect
high-resolution data. And we've been as fast as six weeks, really,
from initial discovery campaign to structure-enabled
situation. And the other advantage is that
we've done this now on a large number of targets, so we have data we can tap into.
And I'm just going to give you one brief example of
chemical probe discovery. So we had, again, together
with Nathaniel,
found that V1 is degradable by
cereblon ligands. Those molecules always had
some casein kinase activity that really hinders you to do the right
biological experiments. We applied the pipeline I just showed you,
and because we have the reference data of other screens, we can prioritize
molecules with high selectivity.
On the right is a straight out of the screen.
There's no chemistry that happened on this molecule.
It's a potent and selective E1 degrader that has good enough
properties to really use it as a selective chemical probe.
And I think this is really the power of accumulating all of the data, where you can
select the molecules that have your desired profiles early on.
I want to now use the last five minutes to switch gear a little bit and talk about
what I really think where the field is going.
And if some of you have attended presentations by Neomov, Triana, and
others over the last couple of days, I think you've seen some of those examples as
well. And this is how we go beyond these
classical or canonical DGRAN-containing complexes and really
expand the scope of
cereblon. And
one of the problems we set on to tackle a
couple of years ago are these close paralogs, and this is,
for example, the histone acetyltransferases, but this is true for a couple of other
classes as well.
And we particularly focus on KAT2A,
a histone acetyltransferases. And I'm going to spare you biology
today because this is a structural biology session.
But the idea was, can we make molecules that are explicitly selective for A over
B, which has been impossible using traditional inhibitors
or PROTAC approaches?
And
started by a screen, and what's interesting here is that there is a single
compound in the entire data set that initially showed
degradation of KAT2A. Encouragingly, it was
already out of the gate selective for B.
It also worked as a small molecule degrader
in all the canonical ways. So it's dependent on cereblon, it's
dependent on the proteasome system, and the minimally reconstituted
system in vitro using just the ligase E1, E2,
ATP, and ubiquitin is sufficient to get ubiquitination
off of KAT2A.
Hundreds of compounds later, that really was driven by
Mong, and Sam was this
partner in crime for all the biology and biochemistry and structures,
led to a compound with
good potency and efficacy
by retaining all of the selectivity for KAT2A and dialing out
the undesired effects such as GSPD1 degradation.
So this now is a clean, selective degrader of KAT2A,
leads to downstream downregulation of H3K9
acetyl, which you would expect, and really doesn't recruit anything.
So on the left, you see global proteomics.
There's no degradation of GSPD1 or GSPD2.
No other off targets. On the right, you see affinity purification mass spec,
same thing, selective recruitment of KAT2A.
So really selective chemical probe.
And one of the reasons we were so interested is because there's been a lot
of talk about this target out there, and there's a lot of notion that you need
both KAT2A and B degradation. But in paralog screening
data from Bill Sellers' lab at the Broad,
we had seen that most of the activity really comes
from the A component. So dual knockout of A and B
looks like KAT2A single knockout, but KAT2B single knockout is
largely inert. So we thought there was a real opportunity here.
And that recapitulated in low throughput experiments
using now just a couple of cell lines selected from DepMap based on their
dependency. And you can see that you get
selective effects on some, but the insensitive cell lines
don't respond and don't have time to show.
But that's also reflected in downstream PD markers.
We've worked then with Scott Armstrong's lab,
particularly Wallace and Alba, to
confirm this in vivo and conducted a PDX experiment in a
highly aggressive AML model, where again, we see
anti-leukemic effects. And this is
the correspondent PD data. So you can see on the right that in the treated
animals, you get complete loss of 2A, and you get corresponding loss of histone
H3K9 acetylation, so as expected.
These compounds still have some PK challenges, so we didn't quite fully cover
the target, and I think once we do that, we can be even better.
The key
question that remained was how does this work?
How do we get this explicit selectivity?
And we immediately noticed that there was no real DGRAN in
KAT2A. There was nothing that really resembled anything we had seen
before. And so we determined cryo-EM structures
of this complex, and you can see that it really wedges across the
entire cereblon interface. And then you have the small molecule
that engages the single tyrosine on a helix, really grabbing on this one
little feature to now create this large composite interface
and providing
selectivity.And
really important for this recruitment are two loops on cereblon on the right and
the left side that also form complexes, which now for us
really leads to an
image we use or
analogy we use with antibodies, where we think that similar to
IgGs, you need a composite interface that constitutes
some loops, such as CDR1 and 2 and antibodies,
and then really high diversity around the key
specificity determinant, which in IgGs would be the CDR3.
And it's very similar in how these molecules work.
And this becomes even more obvious once you look at the KAT2B complex.
So we meanwhile also have a molecule that recruits both A and B.
And you can see that the recruitment motif is actually
exactly the same. I don't have a slide for that, but it's the same tyrosine in the
same position. And specificity arises from one of these
auxiliary loops, which perfectly fits
on A on the left, but really gets distorted in B, so you need
to add a lot more binding energy somewhere else to overcome this
unfavorable confirmation. And so your
secondary loops can also really add selectivity to your
molecules. So with this, and since I'm out of time,
I'll just quickly summarize.
What I've shown you is really our ongoing quest to expand
the druggable proteome by pushing the boundaries of molecular glue discovery.
And I think we've really gone from initially taking the proximal targets of the
zinc finger transcription factors to extending to DEK1 containing non-zinc finger
targets. And now I would say we're in the space where we're really thinking this
is universally applicable if we cover enough chemical space.
Didn't have time, but we used a lot of structural biology to uncover other
degradation systems, such as
BCS6 and other examples.
And I've also told you how we use high throughput degradomics
combined with structural enablement and
ever more computational methods to rapidly enable new programs
and develop chemical probes that are highly selective and active.
All of this is an amazing team effort. I mentioned some people along the way.
The KAT2A work was really driven by Mong and Sam.
The pipeline is really a lot of different people.
The
V1 work was key, and then the many, many key
collaborators. Nathaniel, always been my partner in crime for
chemistry, Ben, Scott, and many, many others. And happy to take questions.
Thank you, Eric. That was beautiful.
So, questions for Eric?
May- Maybe I can ask you, what is the reason or reasons that
the cost actually of the mass spec enabled or what you call
degradomics, why that decrease so much and so fast?
So it's a couple of things. One, really the inflection point was
the
emergence of these data-independent acquisition methods, which
correspondingly had also emerging very fast instruments.
And so you can collect the same amount of data in much shorter time.
Only possible because we have advances in the computational side.
Right.
All of these data-- the problem of dealing with very convoluted
spectra, deep learning is really good at.
Deep learning.
And so that comes together, and then we also made changes on the way we
prepare the samples.
That's great. Yes.
Hi. That was an excellent talk.
It is an amazing pipeline and what you have created, an infrastructure.
I'm wondering, most of the data is cereblon based.
What about other E3 ligase substrate receptors that
are less known and they're employed by molecular
glues?
So I focused this talk really on cereblon, but we have similar
data on other ligases. Not as much, but we're building
that. So yeah. It's universally applicable.
Thank you for the great talk. I'm curious about the database you're building and
how you balance
screening structural diversity as opposed to screening your compounds
against multiple cell lines, because as you screen across different cell
lines, you see different protein targets.
So it's a trade-off, right? We
can't do all of all. So we've settled on a
number of cell lines we have that we feel like are pretty orthogonal
and provide a good representation of
proteome space.
We sometimes screen very-- If we have a specific target in mind or a specific
disease indication, we may look into that.
But on the large-scale data generation, we have to restrict the
number of cell lines we do.
Hi. The nice talking. I'm a medical
oncologist. I'm not very expert in
the molecular glue.
So I have maybe a naive question that compared
with other drugs, what's the advantage of the molecular
glue in the therapy in
oncologist?
So I think the major advantage is the ability to
access targets in pharmacology you couldn't access before because you
don't need a pocket on the target side.
We can engage, in the case of KAT2A, we engage essentially a
flat surface,
or the zinc finger transcription factors.
There's not much other ways of targeting those.
So to me, that's the major advantage.
That it really gives you access to targets that weren't accessible before.
Hi. Very inspiring talk.
I'm interested, as you're trying to scale this up at a high level, how difficult is
it to set up the Turbo ID screens for, say, new effectors?
We can get very cheap mass spec, but how hard is it if you're
running these screens to set them up?
Well, we don't use any Turbo ID-
Okay
... because that would
require cell line engineering.The devil is in the detail,
right? We publish all the protocols, so they're pretty straightforward, but
the devil is in the detail,
sorting out automation, sorting out kind of all the little pieces.
Whenever you pile up many steps, there's a lot of little
things that could go wrong. But generally, they're pretty straightforward, I would
say.
Awesome. Thank you.
Okay. We'll take a final question.
Very nice talk. Do you have some strategy
to improve the potency starting from the initial hit
compound?
So we try to be very rapidly structurally enabled.
So we really try to go in and get structures early
and often, and then it's structure-based drug design,
largely.
All right. So please join me in thanking Eric again for this fantastic
talk.
So next speaker will be Natalia Dzura from UCSF,
and that will be about these mechanisms of
PI3K activation by RTKs
and cancer-associated mutations. Natalia.
And how do I switch between the screens?
The mouse.
Okay. All right. Sounds good.
Hello, everyone. Thanks so much, Babis, for the invitation, and
thanks for all of you who came to listen to the talk.
So, our lab is primarily
interested in structure function studies of protein kinases, in
particular receptor tyrosine kinases.
But more recently, we have ventured into
characterization understanding of the most famous lipid kinase,
phosphatidylinositol-3-kinase alpha, or PI3-kinase alpha.
And today, I'm going to tell you what we've learned about the
mechanism of its activation.
So before I start, I would like to acknowledge one person
who really did all the work, which is Hayarpi Torosyan.
She's a student who recently graduated from my lab and was co-mentored by
my very close collaborator on this project, Klim Verba at
UCSF. This work is on bioRxiv, and as of
a couple of days, it's finally in press, so we're very excited about
it.
So PI3-kinase, as you probably all know, is a very potent oncogene.
When it comes to the frequency of mutations, it only
gives first place to p53, and it happens across a
variety of different tumors. And it's more frequently mutated
than KRAS, for example, or BRAF. A really
important target.
There is a lot of therapeutics that have been developed to study
PI3-kinase, but they all have limitations
of different kinds. So there is still a huge interest in understanding how
we can do better in inhibiting PI3-kinase in
cancer. And
obviously, really a deep understanding of how it's activated is a
key to that process.
So PI3-kinase is a lipid kinase. In an
auto-inhibited form, it actually resides in the cytosol.
And it is recruited to the membrane where its substrate PIP2 is
located by a couple of different ways.
The main way is phosphorylated receptor tyrosine kinases,
or RTKs, that bring in PI3-kinase so it can
now phosphorylate PIP2 to PIP3 and initiate
recruitment of PH domain-containing proteins,
most famously AKT, which is a downstream effector of
PI3-kinase,
promoting cell survival and all these important
downstream
processes.
Interestingly, Ras is an important yet
very elusive part of PI3-kinase activation.
It directly binds to PI3-kinase, but it has been shown not to
really be essential for PI3-kinase signaling under normal
conditions, but really help in potentiating its signaling
and perhaps ramping up the amplitude of PI3-kinase signaling through
the mechanisms that are really poorly understood.
And obviously, mutations in PI3-kinase, they are scattered all over this
large holoenzyme, with quite poor understanding
of most of their mechanisms of action
and how they might be shaping the response to
PI3-kinase-targeting inhibitors.
So to understand PI3-kinase, one has to kind of understand the architecture of this
rather large holoenzyme, which is quite complicated.
It's a constitutive heterodimer between the catalytic subunit
p110 and the regulatory subunit p85 that
are in this very intimate interaction with each other,
primarily driving autoinhibition of the enzyme.
Ras binds to the Ras-binding domain of the catalytic subunit, and
the phosphorylated tails of receptor tyrosine
kinases engage SH2 domains in the regulatory subunit.
As you can see, so there are two SH2 domains, NSH2
domain, and CSH2 domain. They're connected by this
deceivingly called ISH2 linker domain.
It's actually a long coiled coil. It's not an SH2 domain.
All structures which are
currently solved in PDB of PI3-kinase show it in the
auto-inhibited form. And in this form, only two domains
of a regulatory subunit, the N-terminal SH2 domain and this linker
domain, are resolved and show this really strong
inhibition.
PI3-kinase is known to be activated by binding to phosphorylated
tails and by being recruited to the membrane.
But there are-When we started this project, there were
no structures of PI3 kinase in the active conformation, which was
quite mind-boggling to us.
So out of all, more than 100 structures available, zero
are in the active
form, and we hypothesized that this might be because nobody ever actually
tried to solve the structure of PI3 kinase in the context of the
membrane, which is really where it becomes activated when it
encounters its substrate PIP2.
So we thought this would be an interesting angle to try to see
if we can tackle this holy grail in PI3 kinase
activation.
And, the reason why we are really interested in it is because the
expertise of my lab is really studying her receptor signaling.
And in the context of this very important oncogenic subunit,
HER2, HER3 heterodimer,
HER3 receptor, which is actually catalytically inactive, is a
super scaffold of PI3 kinase. It has six
phosphorylation sites, which are phosphorylated by HER2, that create
this very interesting and puzzling multivalent mode of recruitment of
PI3 kinase to the membrane.
And
we still fully don't understand what it does to PI3 kinase signaling and
why this is important, and we think that our recent work might shed some
light on why multivalency might be making a difference in
regulating amplitude of PI3 kinase signaling.
Another reason why we were interested in PI3 kinase was
because of our collaboration with Navan Krogan and Jennifer Grandis at
UCSF, and Silvio Gatkin at UCSD, who did a very
interesting experiment in which they looked at the associated
proteomes of individual oncogenic PI3 kinase
mutations
and noticed that they slightly differ, and different mutants tend to
bind to different proteome in a cell.
And there is this very interesting red cluster, which you can see here, which when
you zoom in, you will see that certain mutants really
enrich these proteins. And one of these proteins is HER3,
and the other ones is Gab1 and IRS1, which are also proteins
that are multivalent recruiters of PI3 kinase.
So there is something interesting between this ability to bind a
lot of subunits of PI3 kinase and oncogenic potential of
PI3 kinase mutants, which we thought was very interesting.
So how do you start this? So we thought, well, in order to really finally
look at PI3 kinase in the active conformation, we should provide all the
things that it needs to become activated.
And there is sort of a menu of things that do that, the
activating inputs like RAS and phosphorylated tails,
perhaps its substrate PIP2, and of course, the membrane.
In our lab, we use lipid nanodiscs, which are really
small artificial membrane bilayer pieces that we
use for
reconstitution of proteins at the membrane and use cryo-EM to
look at the structures of these membrane-associated
complexes.
So we started by purifying full-length PI3 kinase and
putting it on the membrane of the lipid nanodiscs, and that was
actually a huge failure. PI3 kinase really didn't want to associate with lipid
nanodiscs.
But what really changed was when we premixed PI3 kinase
with farnesylated K-RAS that we have gotten from
NCI for the RAS initiative.
And when we formed the complex with K-RAS, now this
farnesyl moiety
presumably drove this complex to the membrane, and we were able to
form stable complexes and do some cryo-EM analysis of
these complexes. But we were stuck at relatively low
resolution, so we couldn't really resolve anything.
What ended up being a very interesting development
in this process was getting our hands on the molecular
glue, which I'm sure Eric will appreciate.
It was given to us by Frank McCormick at UCSF.
He has been developing it in collaboration with other groups.
This glue binds to the RAS binding domain of PI3 kinase and to
RAS and brings them together in a stable conformation.
This allowed us to get a high-resolution structure of this entire
complex at the surface of the lipid nanodisc.
And this is what I'm showing you. Here with K-RAS being in orange
and the catalytic subunit in blue with ABD
domain in that subunit in lighter blue and the portion of the
regulatory subunit in gray.
We couldn't really see the surface of the nanodisc, but when you look at the
low-pass filtered map, we can see the nanodisc.
It's very curiously oriented at an angle to this
hollow enzyme. And you can see that the farnesyl moiety of
K-RAS is making an interaction, kind of inserting itself into this
lipid nanodisc right here, which was interesting.
We are very excited because this data set allowed us
to analyze different classes that allowed us to actually
build a trajectory of PI3 kinase being
increasingly more activated. And what you can
hopefully appreciate is the disappearance of the gray and light
blue density as we move from class one to class three, which are these
auto-inhibitory domains that keep PI3 kinase in an inactive
state. And the slow dissociation of the inhibitory
subunits have never been seen before in the solution structures of PI3
kinase that were obtained before.
So to us, what that meant was that bringing PI3 kinase
to the membrane allowed it to peel off these auto-inhibitory domains and started
becoming more
active.Despite
the fact that it seemed more active, the
active site of PI3 kinase actually was quite far away from the
membrane surface, and that worried us a little bit and told us that there is
something that still blocks PI3 kinase from adopting a fully active
conformation.
And that thing seemed to be a rather mysterious extra
density that was kind of buttressing between PI3 kinase and a lipid
nanodisk.
And we really didn't get to a high resolution in this region of the structure to
know exactly what it is. But by using AlphaFold, we have a pretty
good guess that what it might be is actually never seen before,
C-terminal SH2 domain of regulatory subunit.
This is really interesting because our structure suggests that this domain
directly interacts with lipids at the membrane,
and there are actually, as you might all know, SH2 domain
interacts with phosphorylated tyrosines.
But there is actually a lot of studies showing that some SH2 domains
make pretty good interaction with phospholipids and including
CSH2 domain of PI3 kinase. So it seems to us that this
interaction might be an additional check that PI3 kinase might
be making before it gets fully activated that needs to be
released for activation. So what can release this check?
Well, we figured that what might help is actually if we include a
substrate of PI3 kinase in a lipid nanodisk, and we
added PIP2 to our lipid mixture. And when we solved the
structure of this complex on the PIP2-containing nanodisks,
now we saw that the entire holoenzyme reoriented itself and
really docked into the lipid bilayer and made very, very
intimate interactions with the lipid bilayer.
That was really interesting and exciting and particularly,
consequential for the active site of PI3 kinase.
I didn't really tell you much about it, not to overload you with details.
I just want you to pay attention to this yellow K12
region, which is a helical region, predicted to be helical, although
had never been seen to be helical in any structures
of PI3 kinase so far.
We really don't know that because we've never had structures of PI3
kinase in the active conformation.
So when you compare a structure of this region in the inactive
state, shown here on the left in this class one, and in
our PIP2 structure, you see that this helix now
becomes a true helix, and it swings all the way 180
degrees in our PIP2-engaged holoenzyme
structure. And this is accompanied by the conformational change
in the activation lobe. And what this allows actually
is to capture a substrate of PI3 kinase in the active
site. This is the first time this has been seen
in
structures of PI3 kinase. Literally in our complex, PI3
kinase grabs PIP2 from a nanodisk and
interacts with it in its active site.
So this helix, the swinging of the helix 180 degrees is really
essential for activation and coordination of the lipid.
But what this made us really excited about is this
most common oncogenic mutation in PI3 kinase, histidine
1047, which is mutated in one-third of human
cancers to an arginine. And we always knew that this
histidine is at this hinge region
right before helix 12 starts.
And what we think is happening is that what a mutation of the
histidine, which is really essential for keeping helix 12 in an active
state through the interaction with this tryptophan 1051,
this interaction is disrupted by an arginine mutation,
allowing swinging of the helix and adopting this active conformation,
perhaps
more readily than in the wild-type enzyme, driving
oncogenic activation of PI3 kinase.
And lastly, what was really exciting to us is that this extra
density that we see for this mysterious C-terminal SH2 domain
actually is exactly where the active
conformation of helix 12
is. So what we think is really
happening is that the C-terminal SH2 domain, this
location between the membrane and the holoenzyme, is a real
auto-inhibitory step that provides additional check to
prevent PI3 kinase from adopting an active conformation when
it doesn't have to do it.
And lastly, what we did is we added one more component
to our complex, which is phosphorylated tails from the
HER3 receptor, and really starts with a very simple
component, which is just two tyrosine sites,
phosphorylated tyrosine sites.
And when we did that,
and we got two different classes of
complexes. One of them was very similar to our
PIP2-only reconstruction, where PI3 kinase was really
engaged with a lipid bilayer and fully active.
But another portion of the particles formed this really interesting
complex that migrated to the edge of a nanodisk with two
KRAS molecules inserting their farnesyl moieties
into the lipid bilayer, promoting dimerization of the
entire PI3 kinase holoenzyme, something that has never been seen
before.
This dimer has really a large dimerization interface,
and what it does, it completely prevents
reassembly of auto-inhibited state of PI3 kinase.
You can see here our dimer structure is overlaid on an auto-inhibited
structure of PI3 kinase, and you can see that association of this gray
and light blue domain is impossible if PI3
kinase dimerizes. So we think what happens is that
this dimericPreviously not observed state
of PI3-kinase is really a fully activated state that
is less likely to equilibrate back to an auto-inhibited state.
So to sum up what we have learned from all this
work for PI3-kinase activation,
we think that we can propose a trajectory for how it is activated.
In the auto-inhibited states, it's fully in the cytosol.
It can get to the membrane, but in the absence of
fully activated components, the C-terminal SH2 domain
might be preventing its engagement with the substrate by blocking,
really binding fully to the membrane bilayer.
Now, with the help of Ras,
and the presence of PIP2, now PI3-kinase can engage fully
in the membrane. And with the presence of phosphorylated tails,
which probably should be drawn even earlier because they really provide this
initial recruitment, what happens, you switch to this state where
PI3-kinase might be adopting this active dimer
that now is less likely to equilibrate back to the
auto-inhibited confirmation. And we think that the
power of this multivalent scaffolds might actually
be pushing this equilibrium towards dimerization,
because you need four phosphorylated
tyrosines to stabilize this dimer of
PI3-kinase.
So, with that, I'm going to finish and
acknowledge the lab and our funding and your attention, and I'm very happy
to answer any questions. Thank you.
Thank you, Natalia. That was brilliant and very interesting.
You used the glue to stabilize the complex and get the high-resolution structure of
that.
Yes, please.
Yeah. That was
wonderful.
As you might know, PI3-kinase tend to like lipid
that are curved. It's more active on things that are
on beads or things like that. Do you think about this in your model and
dimerization?
Yes. Thank you for this question. I didn't really talk about
this curiosity of our dimer being at the edge of the
nanodisk due to the lack of time, but,
in many ways, we're wondering whether this reflects biology
and whether this reflects the
preference for PI3-kinase for more curved membranes.
We don't know. What we're doing right now, we're trying to reconstitute this
complex on more flatter membranes, like large liposomes, to see
whether we can see any differences in
dimerization on different surfaces.
But it's a very, very interesting question, and we're actively thinking about
it. Thank you.
Hi. Robert Blake, Genentech.
Excellent talk. Very fast.
So I was curious about the mutations that activate
PI3K. So are you saying that the
mutations in and of themselves are not sufficient to cause the
activation, that you would need activation of a
receptor and then localization first?
Yeah. This is a very good point and it will...
I am not fully an expert on
the... And I don't think we fully understand it.
There is also a difference with which different mutations will be
activating or will be driving PI3-kinase
autonomous and independent from other activating factors.
The HR mutation, as you might know,
is considered to be relatively independent from RTK
activation,
and has been before proposed to
increase membrane association of PI3-kinase.
And we feel like our structure really explains it, because by
promoting swinging of helix 12, you really
create PI3-kinase that is probably unstable
without associating with the membrane, which will drive a membrane
association. The helical domain mutations, which are also very frequent,
they retain pretty high dependency on
phosphorylated RTKs because these mutations
really dislocate SH2 domains, but PI3-kinase still
needs to bind to phosphorylated peptides to be recruited to the core
of
the
holoenzyme,
where P85 and PTEN interact with each other.
So,
yeah.
We hope that our system now provides a great platform
to address these type of mechanisms. Yeah. It's a great question.
Thank you.
I wonder if you could comment on the fact that
the Ras PI3K breaker drugs are
particularly effective on HER2 over
expressing cancer cells relative to KRAS
mutant cancer cells. So how do you see that being accounted for by
your structural information that you've got?
Yes. That is a very, very good question,
and-I would
say one thing to consider in this case is how much these
tumors are so dependent on HER3.
The one idea we have in our mind is that because HER3
provides multivalency, it might make PI3
kinase less dependent on the Ras as an additional
anchor point at the membrane.
But that's sort of going the other direction
to this interesting vulnerability of HER2
tumors to the breakers. So I really can't reconcile it right
now in my head, but we're talking about it with
Frank, obviously, and we're hoping to get to the bottom of this.
It's very interesting.
The first thing we want to do is we want to try to make mutations in the dimer
interface and see whether dimerization might be a
factor in this vulnerability.
All right. Please join me in thanking Natalia again for this brilliant talk.
Thank you.
All right. Now, the close of the last
talk actually of this session will be a little bit different, but I guess
also it will highlight the impact and significance of
structural biology, although in this case, the technique that will be used is
primarily NMR spectroscopy. And actually, I will really talk to you about the
conformational landscape of protein kinases and then how this one can be
then exploited therapeutically for the design,
hopefully, of selective inhibitors.
And I'll show you actually, basically in the end, also
some success I think we've had so far.
But first of all, let me
then show you what do we really mean by this conformational landscape.
And,
in kinases, and that's, of course, applies, it's true also for many other
dynamic systems like GPCRs or GTPases and so forth.
You don't only have one single structure that typically
you determine by crystallography or cryo-EM or even NMR for that matter,
but you have a multitude of different conformational states, and
most of them will be populated only at a very small
percentage. Sometimes, for example, 1% or even less than that.
And this is why these states have been really, traditionally,
extremely hard for anyone to experimentally assess.
But it's one of these conformational states will be associated with a
different outcome. And that can be, for example, different
PTM, it can be different ligand binding, it can be different catalytic
activity. And this is also like someone would argue, and definitely actually, I
would argue, that being able to access this multitude of
conformational states is really the next frontier in structural biology.
The problem of even predicting the structure of a
single protein has been largely solved, even for complexes in
that case, and then we've had this one actually before.
But still, all these algorithms are very far away from
predicting this multitude, the multiple conformational states you may
really have present in
solution. And this, I think, now we have so much experimental evidence
about that, that these states are, of course, very, very important.
And then for anyone to be able to understand how, not just kinases,
but any other system, any other proteins for that matter, someone will have to
access, and then hopefully also not only being able to detect them, but
also experimentally determine the structure of that.
Now, before telling you how we can do this one, just to remind you a little bit
actually about how the kinase domain looks like.
Of course, you have the classical N lobe and the C lobe there.
And then I'm highlighting some of the structural features that are
really very important here, is we have this alpha C helix, for
example, that forms this salt bridge with the lysine that coordinates
ATP, and that needs to be in the so-called in conformation to be active.
Then we have the DFG motif here. Of course, we're very well conserved among all
kinases. Aspartate here is also important in
coordinating magnesium as well as for the ADP.
The activation loop needs to be in this extended open conformation so then
the substrate can dock here, and then this is the P-loop,
underneath of which where ATP binds.
And so all of these structural elements need to be perfectly
aligned to have, of course, an active conformation.
And this is for this reason that evolutionary pressure, because of evolutionary
pressure, of course, the active conformation looks so similar
among all kinases. And that's one thing mechanistically, but
also when it comes to targeting,
this also explains why many molecules that bind to
the active state of a kinase, why they have a very poor selectivity
just because, of course, how similar kinases are structurally.
Now, any departure from the structure will result in an inactive state.
And of course, there is probably only one way to form an active state,
but there are multiple ways, in principle, to, of course, get in
inactive states, because the only thing you're trying to achieve here is just being
inactive, and there are apparently many different combinations that you can achieve
that. So one of the questions we've been asking here is that how many of these
different inactive conformations are present to the human kinome?
This is, of course, very important for us to understand all the variety of
mechanisms that kinases they use to inhibit, regulate themselves,
but also how they get dysregulated.
But also, as I'll also show you today, that also presents, I think, the opportunity
for design of selective inhibitors.
And now if someone asks, "Well, okay, but how can we do that?
How we can access these multiple conformational states?" So then I would
say that NMR spectroscopy is probably the best way of doing that
because we can determine structures.
Of course, we do this one in solution, and then we can monitor how structure
changes over time, but also can detect these very low populated
conformational states as low as 1%.
Sometimes, actually, if we use powerful NMR instruments, as low as half percent
of that. We can determine under favorable conditions the structure
of these states, and then also as a bonus, also we have access to the
energetics and the kinetics of these conformational transitions.
Now-At St. Jude, actually, we have massively invested in
these technologies. We have now an excellent lineup of
NMR instruments with our flagship 1.1 gigahertz that
really gives us the opportunity to be able and access
these conformational states. Now, first, I'll show you actually two
examples here, and then I'll show you what is the
mechanistic insight we can gain from that.
Then we can ask, I think, some very interesting biological questions, but also how
then we can, again, leverage this kind of structural information to
be able to
design novel inhibitors for kinases.
Now, we access the ABL kinase. I will just skip you, of course, all the
details. But then once we do this one and then use these new
approaches, we have an NMR wise to manipulate
the spin physics, then we can determine, in this case, with ABL kinase, we
determine, for example, that the kinase domain populates and
samples three distinct conformational states.
One of them is the ground state, which is depicted here, and then when we determine
the structure, then it turned out to be a fully active conformation.
But then also there are two excited states that turn out also when we
determine the structure of those, which is not, of course, trivial because each one
of them is about 5% to 6% populated, but there are
ways and tricks that someone can do this one nowadays.
We also determine the structures of these two inactive states.
And I'll just show you
here, okay, how that really looks like as this one morphs from active state
to the inactive state one, and then you can monitor some
subtle differences. I'll just play this one actually again here. Oops. For you.
Can I go back?
Yeah. Okay, I can go back. So then that will play again.
You can see, for example, DFG here, how it flips 180 degrees
to move into this so-called out position, and this is what now makes this
kinase inactive. And this is the middle, basically,
conformational state in the energetic
diagram you saw here, and
now I'll show you which is much, much more basically pronounced.
The changes you see as ABL moves now from the active
state to the inactive state two. And you will see how, for example,
this phenylalanine moves all the way into the ATP pocket, how the DFG, of
course, flips again to the 180 degrees, and how the A loop also will
close now on the
C lobe, and that will prevent the substrate from binding.
So you'll see these are much more dramatic now, the conformational
changes. And this one, of course, what I really showed you, it really happens in
solution very, very, very fast. That means hundreds of times per second
as the kinase moves from the active state to the inactive state
one, and finally to the inactive state two.
So this is what we have determined here, these three states here,
experimentally active, the inactive state one, inactive state two.
And then one very exciting observation we made back then is that
finally, I could figure out what is the state that
Gleevec, okay, still, of course, remains one of the most selective tyrosine
kinase inhibitors out there. Why is that really so selective?
So it turns out, and this is a crystal structure here of Gleevec bound to ABL,
okay, it turns out actually that Gleevec binds very
selectively to this low populated state.
So then this is a state that is present only for about 5% of the time but
needs to be present for Gleevec to bind.
And then in this paper, actually, we also then explain longstanding
questions about, for example, drug resistance mutations, Gleevec resistance
mutations. And then how, for example, many of them, what they do is that
they don't really, especially the allosteric ones, they don't
really decrease the affinity of Gleevec
by sterically hindering with that, but rather by depleting
and destabilizing this state, and that, of course, now explains
why
Gleevec is so really selective, because it doesn't bind to the active state, but it
binds to a state that is also not really present in other kinases.
Now, very quickly, I'll just show you some more recent data here, where as you move
to the Src family of kinases, so that also includes a number
of very, very important kinases here.
And then in this case, we ask a very specific question that we're
hoping that our approach would really finally give some answers
to. And this is this processive phosphorylation.
So Src family kinase like Src and
Lck and Hijak, for example, are very well known to processively
phosphorylate substrates. In this case, if you look at this 130 cast, that
has up to 15 tyrosine
residues that need to be processively phosphorylated by Src,
because then, of course, creates a multiple number here of
phosphosites too, so then that can recruit now a number
of
proteins here to form this mega complex.
And mechanistically, this is something that is very challenging.
So in order to have a processive phosphorylation as opposed, for example, to a
distributive that would be very random.
So in order for this one to happen, Src or any other SFK for this matter,
has to dock on the substrate and then very quickly
hydrolyze ATP, phosphorylate one site, then
release ADP very quickly.
And then, for example, have them do this cycle over and over again.
And in this case, it's very well known that the rate-limiting step, kinetically
at least, is ADP release. But how kinase is
very fast release ADP has not really been known, not just for
Src, for example, for any other kinase for that matter.
So can we really get some insight into potentially the conformational state
that is responsible for this fast release of ADP?
And what we did to follow the similar approach here with Src
also, and then we determine three also happens, for example, Src 2
also in this caseSample three unique and very
distinct conformational states.
One of them is the active conformation that's about 80%
of the population. Then also we
determined a fully inactive conformation that is present, it's
about 10% or so, and this resembles
basically the fully inactive conformation that Src adopts in
the full length. What is, that is when it is downregulated, this
is the classical structures that were determined by John Curry and Michael Egg
and Steve Harrison back in the days.
But then also very intriguingly,
we're also able to determine a novel structure that we'll call
an intermediate structure because it sits between the fully active and the fully
inactive conformation that had also a structure that
was very unique. It's a structure that when you compare to the
7,000 whatever structures that are available now for human kinases, of
course, the vast majority bound to inhibitors, okay, that was really very
unique and we've not really been able to see this one in any one of the other
kinase. So then someone, of course, that begs the question, what is really the
role of this intermediate state here?
And then when look at the structure of that,
then one of the many insights that will, there are multiple things, but I
just focus only on this ADP here, is that when you
see the ADP dock in, in this case, it's docked into the active
structure, the inactive structure, right?
It's very nicely docked, but in this case, if you try to dock ADP
into this intermediate state, then you see there is these
major steric clashes. And when we measure the ADP
affinity, then we, both the active and the fully inactive have very
high affinity for ADP, but this intermediate state actually had a very
low affinity for ADP, and that made us really
come up with the idea and hypothesis that potentially this is really the
conformational state that needs to be present, to
release ADP. And we've had, run actually
several experiments, and then indeed, we were able
to, in this case, determine that
this excited state, this 5% of this intermediate state,
indeed is the state that is absolutely required for
ADP release. Now, there are of course, many experiments that we
run here,
and, what we can do is that since we have the structural information,
then you can introduce mutations to destabilize this state.
And then when we do this one, then, Src, but also Lck
that
processively phosphorylate the cell receptor, they lose their capacity to
processively phosphorylate their substrate.
So in this case, we did really discover the state that is
responsible for releasing ADP.
Now,
in the final few minutes, I would like just to focus on
how these excited states or these invisible states, they can
provide now opportunities for therapeutic intervention, right?
Because the first part was really about the mechanisms, and that's all actually
very nice and wonderful, but how can this potentially
be exploited now from a therapeutic point of
view? So these invisible states, and we have
very strong evidence, they do reveal
binding pockets that are otherwise, for example, not obvious in the ground state.
So when someone determines the
single major, the energetically most stable state, then,
often many of these pockets, especially allosteric
pockets, they are not really present, but, in these states, they are
transiently open, and we can determine those.
And they have very unique structural features that are not really present in
the ground states. But also when someone, in
principle at least, okay, when someone targets these conformational
states because they are distinct and in many cases, they are
only present in a very small number of kinases,
then in principle, then someone can
design inhibitors with a much higher selectivity.
In fact,
Gleevec was a serendipitous discovery, right?
But it turned out really to be selective because it bound to these inactive low
populated
states. And then we really hope with this one to be able to expand the
number of kinases that we can drug.
So how we can do this, in this case then we follow two different strategies.
One, it is once we have the structure, basically it's the, again, if I
bring up the example with Gleevec, right?
As I said, Gleevec was a serendipitous discovery, but now if you ask the question,
if you already know the structure of this inactive state two, right, and then you
don't really know, of course, you have no idea, you're oblivious to the presence of
Gleevec. Can you design
Gleevec, right? Can you design, let's say, a Gleevec-like molecule to selectively
bind to this conformational state, right?
Because then, of course, selectivity will be higher.
Now, that of course, will be the case in Abl, but in principle, this is something
that someone can do now for any kinase, provided that you have access to
these conformational states. So this is the first approach where we use the
structure, and then we use virtual docking.
We can now
dock up to about 70 billion compounds
on these states, but also use a second approach, which is basically purely
experimentally, where we get now these states, and then we stabilize
them to become the ground states, and we purify those.
And, we just run experimentally large screens, like for example,
DEL here, DNA encoded libraries or fragment libraries and so forth,
with the hope of course, that we'll be able to get the selective inhibitors.
And, going back into BCR-Abl, Abl here and
BCR-Abl, then we ask as a proof of concept, right?
We have the structure. This is a state, the inactive state two is the one where
Gleevec binds. This is the one that has been, of course,
therapeutically unexplored because it wasn't really known it was present.
And now we ask the question, can we use, since we have this structure, can
we design selective inhibitors for this state that will only and
just selectively bind to I one state?
And the answer is yes, we can do
that.And so, like here, I'm just showing you the
results actually we've got into these ones, where we have been able very
quickly, in fact, okay, to generate molecules that bind,
inhibit Bcr-Abl down to like single nanomolar
numbers. And this is now where we are in the process of
just running selectivity profiles for us to try to
understand how really selective these compounds
are. So,
this is something that was highlighted very recently, actually last week, in case
someone wants to take a look at this one in "Nature Biotechnology," how our
approach basically by looking at these hidden or invisible
structures, how this one can be used for the
design of selective inhibitors. And I would like to close really
by saying here that this is a major effort, what I described to you before on
Abl and Src kinase. Now there's a very major effort
where more than 60 people are working on this human kinome to
expand this approach to the entire human
kinome, and this is something that we've been working on more than
150 kinases and trying to describe and access
this conformational landscape, both to understand mechanisms, but as well also
to hopefully exploit this one
therapeutically. Thank you.
If there are any questions.
This one.
Yeah, I have a quick question. I was wondering whether the
intermediary step of Src kinases, the ADP,
the low, is this modified, the balance is modified by substrate, protein
substrate binding?
If this one has a modified substrate binding?
Or if the binding of the protein substrate modifies the balance between the
states.
So if I get actually your question right, it doesn't
bind, this intermediate state, it does not bind to the substrate because the A loop
is closed, right? It's actually partially closed, so that doesn't really bind to
the substrate, and this is one of the reasons. Is that what you're asking?
Yeah. Well, not really, but yes.
Yes.
That answers the question.
Right. Okay. Yes. Thank you.
Hi there. Lovely talk. I've got two questions.
The first is, I'm just wondering whether you've adopted
Roland Dunbrack's necessary and sufficient criteria for
active kinases or if you've been able to recapitulate that in your work.
And then do you have any thoughts about biasing in silico
generation methods, so that we can leverage
co-folding models and things like that for some of these infrequently
populated states?
Yes. So then yes, with active conformations, yeah, we do use
nomenclature that was introduced by Dunbrack.
And we don't really see, of course, any differences
in kinase. Active conformations, they have really to be very
well-defined because even if you have slight departures from
these very well-defined structures, then you don't really have
an active conformation anymore. But when it comes to if
we are asking about the role and whether we can use in silico, or you
mean like AI approaches, for example, to predict the low
conformational states, the answer is that there's
no real algorithm that gets actually close, even close to this.
We have participated-- Well, we were asked to submit some of the targets to CASP
because this is now one of the major areas in CASP to see whether these
algorithms can predict this, go beyond basically the ground structure.
They were very far off from this. Now, again,
this is today, right? Today, which is like Tuesday or whatever,
right? So then who knows what happens next week.
But one of the very big problems, of course, here is that there's no
really training data, right? Because you don't really have many of these
structures
solved, not only for kinases but also for other proteins, especially in the absence
of ligands, right? Because they are just very low populated.
So I think that would be a challenge, but how quickly that can be solved, I don't
really know. Yeah, that's a good question. Thank you. Yeah.
Thank you very much. Very important work, this mapping the human kinome.
Got a question about the virtual docking package approach that-
Yes
... you and your team are using. Which one
are you using, and
which approach has yielded the most utility?
Yes. That's a good question. So we use
VirtualFlow that was designed, but it's actually
developed by Krzysztof Gorgula when he was in the group of Gerhard Wagner,
then Harinder Athari at Harvard. But then we recruited Krzysztof
to be part actually of our project, and now he moved as faculty in my
department. And VirtualFlow is a platform that has, I think,
about 200 plus different docking,
basically, algorithms. And we've used to explore this one, not to
the very great extent, right? Simply because, of course, it's very
expensive computationally to screen 60 whatever
billion compounds for each one of those.
But VirtualFlow, generally speaking, is something that has really given us very,
very good results. We had, I think,
a very good
percentage here in terms of hit numbers for our systems.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
We'll take one final question. Yes, thank you.
Okay. Hi, thank you.
So I wanted to ask about a potential role for the
SH2 domain of Src for the process of
phosphorylation.
Yes.
I'm thinking of examples like Src's phosphorylation
of PKC Delta, and there's one priming site and
then subsequent phosphorylation sites.
So I was just wondering whether SH2 domain is involved, and
whether the involvement of SH2 domain then can drive
conformational changes that attain these intermediate states.
Yeah, that's actually, it's an excellent question. So what do you really need?
The primary role of either the SH3 or the SH2 domains are
to dock on the substrate, right? Because in order to have process
phosphorylation, in this case, Src, for example, has
really to remain bound to the substrate, because in
between cycles, they dissociate.
Then of course, you
don't get process phosphorylation anymore. That becomes distributive.
And there are substrates where instead, in this case, SH3 is the one that
docks on p130Cas, but also there are substrates where SH2
instead is the one that docks, right?
And then all of this one really happens with the goal to extend the
lifetime of the complex, so then you can get the chance to processively
phosphorylate that.
Okay. But does the SH2 domain binding then
affect this high ADP
release?
SH2 binding to what?
The
exchange of the nucleotide on the kinase, is that affected?
You mean SH2 docking on Src kinase? Is that what you mean by binding?
The SH2 docking on the substrate.
Oh, the SH2 docking on the substrate. Well, if there is no-- Yes.
In some cases, if there is phosphorylated tyrosine and the
SH2 can dock, that can help extend the lifetime.
But that's not really necessary. It depends on how quickly ATP
really, ATP gets high. But SH2 is not required for
ADP release, because even if you have the isolated kinase domain with no
SH3 or SH2, that really happens, okay, by itself in terms
of the actual ADP release.
Okay, thanks.
Yes. Thank you. All right, so with that, I guess, I would like to thank
Eric and Natalia for the session, and thank you all for being here with us.
Thank you.